well what about the situation for
primary schools elsewhere in the country
joining me now is the mayor of greater
manchester andy burnham good morning
to you uh heard there from no much
confusion at where he is
what do you believe the policy should be
the government's done a
u-turn and said that all schools in
london primary schools at least will
remain closed
should that extend across the country
i think it should be decided locally um
that's what i've put to the government
today i think you are absolutely right
to say at the start that
people up and down the country parents
teachers
support staff students kids are anxious
today about what's what's happening
and that that has to be sort of
sort of born in mind by people like me
it's gonna be about practical solutions
not politics and that's really really
really important but while i understand
the government's wish to get people back
into school
if they plow on on their current path i
think we'll have a chaotic start of term
tomorrow so what i'm saying to the
government is either
give schools working with local councils
flexibility to set their own start dates
based on the local evidence
or let's have a delay along the lines of
the delay that's been
arranged for secondary schools i think
it has to be one or the other
if they just push ahead i think we'll
see tomorrow morning
some staff perhaps not turning up or
some parents not feeling able to send
their
their students and that won't build
confidence at the start of this new term
so as you explain that there is a lot of
confusion around so therefore wouldn't a
blanket approach
be preferable well i say there is to be
a blanket
approach it should be to delay um
because
there are real concerns in schools that
the the arrangements aren't in place to
make them safe
the schools that i speak to and i do
speak to a lot of head teachers spoke to
some yesterday
um they are worried that they've not had
time to get access to testing there's
worries about ppe
uh there's calls for support with
vaccination um
so you know they are worried special
schools only got the
guidance about reopening gone
5 p.m on new year's eve now i think most
people would say that is completely
unreasonable and for for schools
particularly schools looking after
children with
with disabilities or special needs to
get guidance
late on new year's eve i mean that isn't
an orderly start to the new school term
so what i'm saying today is you know we
do want to see schools reopen but it's
got to be done as safely as possible
so give the ability of schools working
with their
councils to set a flexible start date
and i think that is the the best
way out of this situation that we find
ourselves in today as you said
lots of confusion out there and the
government needs to cut through it and
offer a way out of this the prime
minister boris johnson has just said
that uh he has no doubt
that schools are safe would you agree
with that
well uh he needs to speak to people on
the on the front line he needs to speak
to some parents who have
concerns it's a it's a fairly sweeping
statement
to make when there isn't uh
at the moment enough ppe in schools the
school environment in some cases
isn't properly ventilated uh there are
concerns about distancing i think it's
to say that it's safe across the board
in every school
i don't think is a statement that can be
that can be made without qualification
you need to look at this school by
school locality by locality and that's
what i'm
arguing for today move away from the
sweeping statements and the blanket
policies
and trust people at a local level trust
head teachers
working with council leaders working
with directors of public health to make
the right decisions
because yes in some places it might be
safe here in greater manchester we
actually have
cases that are quite somewhere below the
national average now
so i would imagine some of our councils
might decide
that it is safe to reopen at some point
this week others might want to delay
that's got to be the pragmatic sensible
way forward
from this uh you boarded liverpool their
interim mayor is calling for
a national lockdown and mass testing
is that something that that you might
advocate
well i did say last week when the
government announced
its new tier arrangements that it was an
odd thing to put
78 of the country in tier 4
and 22 in tier 3. so i made the same
call myself last week
let's let's have national arrangements
at this moment in time i think the
tia system anyway i would say there are
doubts about it
it confuses people so let's move to
national arrangements
through january that doesn't have to be
full national lockdown but it does have
to be arrangements that are
are in place to protect the nhs through
what is going to be
a very challenging month and yes we are
working with the government to see more
mass testing we're
going to receive some support from the
military which is very very welcome
welcome indeed but but all of this is is
going to take time to be put in
put in place to come back to the schools
issue it isn't fully in place at this
moment in time and that's why there are
lots of concerns out there
yes and some high-profile labour
politicians have written to
to kierstarma um suggesting that
labour are not holding the government to
account enough and they should back the
unions in calling for
a universal lockdown of schools for the
first weeks of term
well everyone's facing difficult
decisions here everybody wants to see
children back in schools and
we've just got to make sure that that is
done as safely
as possible so i'm sure that uh
kyostama will be looking at these issues
carefully
perhaps the pragmatic approach that i've
suggested today might be something that
he might want to
to advocate i mean i'm just putting
forward my ideas with regard to what i
think is right for greater manchester i
think
in this pandemic we've had too much of
westminster
telling laying the law down and telling
everybody how it's going to be and
briefing their plans late and
i think we need to move to a more local
approach to the management of this
pandemic
though is the kirsten though holding the
government to account
i think he's done it very effectively
throughout this entire pandemic not
just scoring points for the sake of it
but asking the right
questions and over a number of issues
particularly the test and trace
system which still isn't working i think
he's been forensic
over that and held the government to
account he's pressed the government
for more support for areas in the tiers
as
he backed greater manchester when we
were having that argument with with the
government so
yes i mean i think he's done the right
thing i mean nobody wants to see
politicians scoring points at this
moment in time and it's why i said
jillian at the start
today of all days let's not do that
because their parents worried their
kids worried there are teachers worried
about what's going to happen tomorrow
a political row isn't what we need today
but instead
let's debate some practical ways that we
can move this debate forward and i've
come on sky this morning to suggest a
couple
yes and in that debate the vaccination
rollout begins
um the astrazeneca vaccine being
available tomorrow
we've spoken to the bma this morning and
they're saying that there hasn't been
enough
communication with the the government on
this and the rollout is is somewhat
chaotic
well it's really important that it
doesn't become uh
chaotic um so we have laid plans in
greater manchester
uh for a number of vaccination centers
to open up i think
seven will open tomorrow by by tomorrow
all of our main hospital sites will be
uh we'll be delivering the vaccine we
expect to receive the astra of zenica
vaccine
uh tomorrow so we have got a good strong
plan
in place uh what we are worried about
is do we have enough staff on the ground
to deliver the vaccine at a rate that we
would want to to get that
immunity across the population and the
advice i'm getting at the moment from my
team is we don't
and we will need to bring in extra
supports of perhaps recently retired
staff
from the nhs so the concern at the
moment is do we have enough vaccinators
not
necessarily enough enough vaccines to
deliver
uh the the injections in all of the
different the different sites but we
want to work with the government on that
and i think again
we all need this vaccination program to
work so like schools
let's work on the practicalities and not
let the politics take over
don't let the politics interfere andy
burnham uh greater manchester mayor
thank you very much for speaking to us
this morning
you're welcome